good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Monday
everyone I am coming at you live from
The Great Outdoors if you're watching on
YouTube I'll explain in a minute hey Jax
how you doing I'm good I'm a little warm
if I may say how are you doing there let
me tell you not only is it 25
[ __ ] degrees in New York our
studio has no heat I don't know why I'm
on it hopefully it'll be fixed but when
I tell you I'm basically podcasting
outside today it is one degree in here
I'm wearing a beanie that you can buy at
toastmerch.com that says not like other
girls I'm wrapped in a gorgeous blanket
that you can also buy at toastmerch.com
my winter coat and honestly thank God
for toast merch because I was not
prepared for this yeah well you look
cute and you look like you're out in the
field covering I look like a sideline
reporter
don't take risks on treacherous roads
don't swim in the sea don't swim in the
sea don't touch that advice so I do
usually get like worked up when we
podcast and I pretty much end the
podcast like nine times out of ten with
a little underboob sweat so I'm hoping
like just getting really into my
favorite podcast with my favorite
co-host like hopefully that will bring
out you know some body heat who me uh
yeah yeah I hope so too for your sake
because I mean would you rather be cold
or hot it's the age old question it's
the age-old question I would rather be
cold
yeah
so I I just why do I have to be either
like why can't I just be comfortable
yeah but you look cozy
yeah I want to apologize to the
podcasters I'm wearing my big puffer and
like I don't know if it's gonna make
like annoying sound like when I move
yeah
yeah like the kid who wear a parachute
pants to school one day and he just
makes so much noise
like there's always someone in parachute
pants who's walking like
is that a thing yeah or if you had one
pair of parachute pants and you wear
them one day and then you never want to
wear them again I was more of a gaucho
girl
um and also we had to wear skirts to
school so not our whole life
that's like such a niche movie reference
like that our family's obsessed with
that literally I don't know if anyone
knows what it's from that's the way you
should feel your whole life
I will seriously venmo ten dollars to
the first person who comments on YouTube
what movie that's from put your venmo
username I'll send you event mode like
I'll be I'll be shocked the only reason
why they might know is we might have
said it before and cited it we gotta get
more stories
I know well no it's just we have so many
we just go through them all we do so
many here's a story here's a story I had
this conversation with Mario that I
thought would be really interesting
podcast conversation and I want to know
if you feel the same you know how
everyone like is talking about like X
like that you get from people that you
date and everyone of course has their
own icks that are tailored to like who
they are as a person but are there like
General icks that like we all
agree on yeah
okay is this one of them or am I unique
in this experience like let's say I was
dating someone or I was like really into
them and I either saw or I pictured them
in my mind like waiting in a line
that's a you ick it's not a general ick
nobody else finds that other people find
it icky but it's not everybody finds it
icky I thought it was you know like
everybody finds icky like the salad
dressing in the corners in the corner
yeah but yeah some people like don't
have line issues like we do
oh my God like the thought of somebody
even like the hottest man like even John
Mayer waiting in a line like seriously
like vomit I'll kick it up a notch with
a backpack on
wait and that backpack has like um like
like a brown paper bag full of food and
he's gonna like sit down and open up the
brown paper bag like for me seeing
anybody eat food that's like to go or
like in a in a bag like that like for me
like you're never less attractive than
when you're eating food out of like a
paper bag oh that's not an issue for me
I think a paper bag is cute it's like so
homemade lunch like I always wanted that
pack that a lunch in a paper bag I'm so
glad so that other women get the ick and
they don't talk to ladies if you're
worried about your man's strength from
you pack him a nice homemade lunch so
he'll be like oh my wife is so nice she
makes me such nice lunch but then put it
in a paper bag so he repels everyone
great and weigh his backpack down with
bricks so he's like walking around on
shows like this big backpack like
knocking into people like and he looks
like the kind of man who like can't
handle
a lot of baggage but you know my husband
has recently become a backpack user
um and it's actually a very nice
backpack and you know Sierra the singer
and Russell Wilson they have a a
backpack line and he happens to have a
backpack from there I don't know
um
and like I think that like adults
wearing backpacks with exception but
like in general is just like not the
vibe however I'm just glad Ben is using
a backpack like he used to walk around
with like literally like a Morton
Williams plastic grocery bag with like
his charger his computer and like some
papers that he needs and now he has a
backpack but more more backpack more
problems because now Ben's backpack is a
full-blown Pharmacy like I clean it out
once a month and I pull out like bottles
of magnesium zinc Advil Sudafed he's
keeping his immunity up
huge bottles I'm like why don't you just
leave the bottles in the medicine
cabinet and then take them in the
morning get him a little pill Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday thing
and then you clean out his thing once a
week so more jobs for me more yeah
because it's you they're bothering you
these things he didn't come more jobs
today wife my dear my backpack is so
heavy with all my magnesium do you have
he doesn't realize
he's like why is my bag so heavy I'm
like you're literally carrying 45
bottles of Zyrtec like unnecessarily you
take one Zyrtec a day yeah my husband
actually wears a backpack all the time
like he's like when we go when we travel
he wears a backpack when he goes into
office is an exception
um but he has like nice he has a nice
backpack and also like he's very like
his backpack like slides onto his onto
his suitcase like yes all works so it's
very mature it's yeah I'm not gonna
tinker
no don't Tinker Taylor's sold your spy
stinky Taylor
um speaking of Taylor speaking of Taylor
we're gonna speak about Taylor
oh not that Taylor oh are there other
tailors
there's two other Taylors I went to the
Taylor's apartment yesterday Taylor's
tracker and Taylor Donahue because they
were like oh we were supposed to hang
they're like we can't like we have all
this family coming we need to like set
up our Christmas decorations I was like
I'll be there and we had like a nice
little Christmasy afternoon I like
hugged my first stocking we wrapped
Garland it was like really cute like
totally made me want to convert
um and then they they are doing this
thing for the month of December they
have this huge chalkboard that they
wrote out like I saw 25 maybe 50
Christmas movies and they're gonna try
and watch all of them and so when I saw
they posted it I texted Taylor Donahue I
was like do you know that I've actually
never seen Love Actually and she was
like what I was like I know it's just
like something I missed you know
um so she was like okay we'll watch it
and set up Christmas decorations so
that's what I did yesterday we had such
a nice time and I watched Love Actually
and I actually have really unpopular
thoughts
um what a bad movie
like in a good way obviously like I
didn't not enjoy it but I can't believe
it became this like Hallmark this like
uh you had it's like a iconic Christmas
movie when like it sucks what was bad
about it
first of all it's one of those movies
where it's like you meet like 15
different couples and like then you
figure out at the end like how they're
all connected yes uh mind you like four
of them were not connected so I don't
know why we were learning about them
the scene that like everyone knows that
like I've heard about is like you know
someone's showing up to the door with
signs and that's like the worst part
that storyline's the worst storyline
okay that storyline makes no
[ __ ] sense they never finished
they never wrapped it up too it was not
iconic at all that guy was like creepy
as [ __ ] like and rude also the movie was
like
obsessed with fat people like there was
like a million fat jokes and they were
making fun of this like character's
thighs like she was so skinny like I was
shook like it was so weird weirdly fat
phobic like it added nothing to the
storyline like I'm like why are we
making these jokes it was not funny
um
and overall like not good but like I
loved it you know what I mean the little
kid singing All I Want For Christmas
okay I had a problem with that but he
wasn't good enough he should have been
you well it was a girl singing first of
all and oh and she loved the voice of
the little boy no the boy loved her yeah
yeah whatever so so Joanna the girl who
sang All I Want for Christmas not good
like extremely pitchy uh not and all the
parents were it was like supposed to be
this moment it's like wow the girl can
really sing she stunk she stunk
um Liam Neeson was a terrible stepfather
letting his kid run through the airport
getting chased down by TSA and there was
like a 911 component to the film that I
didn't understand either what was that I
haven't seen it in a while so it's it's
in pieces like the beginning of the
movie was like
they mentioned 911 and about how like if
you ever want to actually see love go to
Heathrow Airport when like people are
getting off the plane and like meeting
with their loved ones and then the movie
ends with like people getting off a
plane meeting their loved ones um and I
just didn't know why they brought 911
into it and also it was in Heathrow what
did they say about 9 11.
when the Twin Towers came down something
it was like the monologue at the
beginning I was really thrown off I
wasn't expecting a 9 11 moment
huh it was bizarre and that's not to say
I didn't like it or enjoy it but I
happen to like bad movies so it's it's a
bad movie yeah I mean mostly Christmas
movies are not winning Oscars no but the
way people talk about love actually like
yeah and then there's the Piers Morgan
storyline you know his body double
what's that guy's name he lives on the
lake
the guy who lived down the lake
oh Colin Firth today here's Morgan yeah
that was so cute when he married the
girl from when honestly the movie was
very funny like there was moments I was
cackling like very funny
um
yeah but
made no sense like at the end okay so
like this is what I and Taylor Donny who
was like I love this movie but like
there's so many plot holes and like if
you go online there's like listicles of
like pointing out all the plot holes in
Love Actually but riddle me this because
it goes it's the movie takes course over
like five weeks so you know when it's
the same day like between couples so
it's like Colin Firth decides in the
evening to go fly to Portugal to go save
that girl not safe to go marry that girl
and in the same time that it takes him
to fly to Portugal Liam Neeson and his
kid make it to the airport but wait he
leaves for the airport the same time as
Joanna and her family
and Liam Neeson knows a shortcut to the
airport but Liam Neeson and his son only
make it for final boarding and Joanna's
been there already but they left at the
same [ __ ] time how do you know they
left at the same time
they saw their car drive away and then
drove they were like let's get the car I
know a shortcut then all this time uh
it's what been like an hour two hours
Colin first made it to Portugal and got
in a cab like I don't think London and
Portugal are so far away
delays no I saw him go into the
commercial terminal
maybe he flew private there's just a lot
of plot holes that's not to say it's not
a good movie it was good but like it was
very bad and I think we should you know
acknowledge that
yeah I mean
I think it's like a Christmas movie like
and it's it's I just you laughed you
smiled like you said it's good like
that's all you need from your Christmas
movies like how much how much to make
fun of Chris like every homework I watch
we sit there making fun and it's a great
time but the way people talk about this
film like with such reverence I was just
expecting more
well that's what happens when you watch
a movie 20 years too late and you missed
the zeitgeist that's everything
so true when we watch First Wives Club
and we're like what's this
yeah oh that's so true I definitely like
missed it because it's not a part of my
holiday Nostalgia so I don't have like a
special place for it in my heart
although it was truly star-studded oh
another plot hole like the [ __ ] happened
with Professor Snape and his wife like
we know he was acting out buying his
assistant jewelry because she was
extremely provocative
um the wife found the necklace
confronting him about it then what
open to interpretation
did you watch that new movie with the
tailors I saw they watched it spirited
uh so I had to leave because I had a
dinner last night they were like putting
it on as I was leaving and I really
wanted to watch it with them it's a Ryan
Reynolds Will Ferrell yeah and it's a
new Christmas movie it looks really good
I've heard it's really good I think that
it's something that could potentially
unite people's this holiday season add
it to your list with crawdads
add a tier listed with crawdads yes I
agree
on the Orient
and Death on the Nile
if you're in our list of family friend
mode
even though we added crawdads to our
list of like good movies to watch with
family it is worth mentioning there are
like two sex scenes maybe three
do we see parts we see stuff we see not
Parts but like stuff I think it's fine
everything has sex scenes these days
like literally I know it's what are
families supposed to get together and
watch CoCo melon I don't know I'm soon
Coco melon is going to be having sex no
I know also
foreign
I'm unfamiliar with Coco and count your
blessings
I know
we have a great show because it's Monday
and that means we have a bit of TV recap
because Jackie watched a new episode of
Yellowstone and I watch a new episode of
White Lotus and I'm all caught up on
White Lotus so we will discuss in the TV
recap but not before delivering five
amazing life-changing stories you know I
actually sent you a couple stories did
you have them but there was a surplus
today of stories so that's really
exciting they are probably in the words
of Liz Lemon when it rains it pours in
the words of Luke Combs probably four
out of five are of equal importance so
the order is not in any particular order
thank you for mentioning that that's
that's really good to know because I
don't want anyone to think like oh I
think this is more important like number
one and number four could be
interchangeable really and that rarely
happens I do want to mention just one
more time that this glorious blanket
that's keeping me warm and the beanie on
my head are both available at
toastmerch.com if you don't know what to
get for the toaster in your life for
this holiday season Hanukkah Kwanzaa
Christmas make sure to head to
toastmerch.com a lot of our holiday
merch is gone I know the peach house
slippers are gone I believe both toasty
crew necks are gone but there's still
some sickening items still some
sickening items blankets mugs ornaments
pajamas I was living in my pajamas this
weekend they're so delicious and Delight
the truckers for toast March are here
did you hear truckers for toasty pajamas
they said girls we can't drive in
anything else these are the best and
we'll wear the black ones in the winter
and the cream ones in the spring summer
spring summer joggers because joggers
how amazing and comfortable they are
100 don't take our word for it take the
truckers
right if you can't believe us believe
the truckers because honestly nobody
is keeping this country together nobody
is doing more for the country nobody's
doing more for the country than the
truckers literally
literally literally oh by the way I need
engagement Chicken on Friday night I
know we were talking about the toast and
I said I would make it and any luck so
it was so good I've never made a whole
chicken before
but I think the best thing about it one
it's a really easy prep and thing to
make like you just slice um you don't
have to peel and chop the garlic you
just stuff them in and you just put it
all in the oven it's really kind of
idiot proof the hardest thing that I
found was touching a whole ass chicken
raw never did it before I didn't expect
that I was gonna be so squeamish
and the organs are in the inside right
yeah you got to like take out the
gizzards it was it was I really did not
see that I don't think I'm like
you know so precious like that and I was
not okay like the [ __ ] pause it was
if anything was ever gonna like make me
be one of these people it's like I can't
eat a living life
oh yeah man handling raw chicken was
wild but do they not sell the chickens
de-gutted
I'm sure if you go to a butcher but I
didn't get it from a butcher I got it
from a supermarket
they have a kosher yeah like Empire does
pre-packaged oh I guess you're right
they do so
um
if the chicken was amazing it was
perfectly cooked like the timing was
Perfection it was juicy moist everything
like I really think that
it's the thing to give that you're the
man in your life or the woman the push
that they need to pop the question
no that's
that's everything like the way I crave
homemade meals but like like will not do
anything about it like my kitchen has
actually never been more Barren during
covet I went through like a phase where
I made like schnitzel once and like a
taco and I'm back to square one like and
I have no interest I need to get I need
to get a chef you have a chef your
husband I know I just don't let him cook
he makes such a big mess and he never
cleans and even when he does clean and
in his mind he's done like a really
thorough job like the entire kitchen is
just covered in a layer of Grease
yeah I mean I can't feel sorry for you
you have a living Chef your husband if
you want homemade food he loves to cook
you like don't let him I don't it
couldn't be it couldn't be more gorgeous
for you actually Zach and I went on a
date night Saturday night and we went
out to a restaurant and the food it was
really nice like we wound up having a
really good time but I was thinking
about like what my dream date night
would be since nobody asked and it just
said no but the night was sprung upon me
and I was like okay if someone actually
wanted to like gift me a gorgeous date
night that like
I'm interested and this is my dream date
night at this stage in my life ladies
mamas let me know if you feel me
redheads too
Zach cooks dinner for me like a good
like just like how I cook for him like a
perfect meal from the cookies does that
cook no however he can't take too much
time so that he's like not available to
help me with Harry and he can't get a
mess either or alternatively he could
hire a chef to come to the house but
then like
I don't want you want to know that the
chef was there you know what I mean I
just wanted a perfect home-cooked meal
that we get to enjoy at our kitchen
table together then we go to bed we each
read our separate books I would say
every 30 minutes to an hour we share
with you we share with each other what
we've read what we've learned and how
we're feeling about the book that we've
read
go back read some more share some more
then from there
cameras out
your maps on wait that sounds nice
except like when I'm reading don't
[ __ ] talk to me and I don't care what
the [ __ ] about like you're reading you
know what if someone's reading something
interesting and they were hitting with
some facts then I would need to read it
myself if I found it interesting it's
also well one I like talking about what
I'm reading but two I want to make sure
the tax doing his or anything so I'm
like you have to question your teacher
wait speaking of dating do you want to
hear the funniest thing yeah I turned on
my like iPhone 4 this weekend because I
wanted to find footage remember when we
went to the 1989 tour which was in like
2015. yes
everyone on Tick Tock is like sharing
like he's here's what I sat for X Tour
so I wanted to participate and I could
not find like I had to go back to like
my college phone I guess I forgot I was
still in college when we went to 1989.
so I turned on this like crusty old
iPhone I found what I was looking for
I'm shocked it turned on I know I found
some great like old family photos and
videos it was nice and then I went into
my text messages and I started reading
my text messages with Ben
and the way I should not be married
right now like I was such a [ __ ] and I
really don't use that word like I was
such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh why on God's green Dylan dally Earth
Ben stuck with me because of course I'm
lovely now and I've matured but I was
like 1920 I had a boyfriend I thought
like nothing and no one could [ __ ]
touch me [ __ ] oh and I had like started
to get like a modicum of Fame I was out
of [ __ ] control oh my God these texts
like I could not have been Ruder more
dismissive I didn't even want to show
Ben because I didn't want him to like
think like yeah why did I marry that
[ __ ] yeah and be like all these years
like he thought that he was overreacting
no and I was like I can't validate his
feelings I was shocked like I was such a
[ __ ] and like all we did was fight what
like give me an example
Jesus
okay so like Ben had sent me something
or maybe called me and I was in class
oh no no no okay okay
it was really mean so I was in school
and Ben had graduated and was working
and
he sent me a text to like his boss at
the time who was like really mean to him
like finally complimented him on
something
so I didn't respond I was in a
three-hour lecture
and then after lecture I was like hey
sorry I just got out of class he was
like did you see my text
and I'm like yeah I did sorry I was in a
three-hour lecture and I didn't have
time to respond that your [ __ ] boss
was nice to you for once
like so rude like for what you know like
for what nobody nobody Claudia
like so rude actually it made me feel
really bad like I know that I was like a
really like I was like a nightmare when
I was like a teenager and like in my
late teens early 20s like we know that
um but to see it like in front of me
like made me actually really sad so I
was really nice to Ben yesterday oh
I haven't been like that like I'm 28 I
haven't been like that for like six
years but like in we've been together
for ten so like in those first couple of
years when like it was my first
boyfriend and I like thought I was such
hot chick it was like I got a boyfriend
I had to make it everyone's problem
mostly pens mostly Ben's yeah that's
funny
it was like it was actually like a
really hard thing for me to like look at
that's but that's that's good of you
yeah I know it's called growth girly
it's called introspection
introspection and now I'm just like you
want to hear about stuck with rose
said I had a moment like that this
morning totally dissimilar but someone
commented on the redhead saying I
listened to the first episode of the
redheads I just listened to it and
Jackie said her favorite book genre is
rom-coms
hello isn't that funny I've been like
reading for like four months when we
started and now like that's probably
that's what everyone gets into reading
yeah it is it is the gateway drug
I'm still uh high on the gateway drug I
started the idea of you that book you
recommended based on like Harry Styles
fan fiction and it's cute it's fun fresh
fun and it's yeah it's like so you
it's like so delusional so may no but
like Harry Styles rum spicy
not that spicy
maybe not yet
no I'm like 40 in
no but don't they have to like
they've already started oh they've
always they've been together they start
right at the beginning which I liked oh
cute
yeah like that'll make you wait like for
the characters to fall in love like no
they're together yeah that's like with
enemies to lovers books it's like 80
until anyway enemies to lovers is like
is an amazing Trope but the fact that
like in a movie or in a TV show like
they don't fall in love till like 80 and
it's so annoying or they don't even like
acknowledge your feelings until like 80
in yeah what's your favorite Trope
what's my favorite
um rom-com Trope yeah not enemies to
leathers
[Music]
maybe like unlikely
pairings
you know because that's like It Happened
One Summer like they were just so so
unlikely yeah my favorite Trope I think
is
um like every summer after love and
other words like childhood lovers who
like go through trauma United and then
reconnect yeah that's sweet it's like
nobody knows me better than my best
friend from the lake for 12 Summers you
know yeah
yeah true
comments what's your favorite trope
yeah
um and Mr lovers is a good one like mean
man sweet girl that's a good one what
about mean girl
the story is sure and then that's us
literally don't send this episode to Ben
I won't but someone will
um so without further uh do here are the
factors oh the straight sound Brethren
Bruce was being so much this morning oh
my God I woke up two hours before my
alarm because I had such a sad dream I
actually can't even talk about it I woke
up crying I'm gonna cry again oh my God
don't do it don't share
okay I slept so deeply with one of those
mornings where I it took me like a
minute to figure out what day it was
um so I actually slept way less because
of my traumatizing dream and I actually
think the conversation we had last week
about sleeping less like I feel amazing
interest hunt 12 to 7.
12. let's wait for you what was keeping
you up I couldn't fall asleep oh my
goodness no way no but then I woke up at
seven I'm like I gotta blow out I took
my time I watched White Lotus like I had
so much time I love it where did you get
a blowout in my living room nice
yeah it was nice garages you can't tell
because I'm wearing a stupid [ __ ]
beanie and a jacket and it was a big old
waste of my time and money but you know
who you are today assisted
beanie Felts too
I'm literally Beauty feldstein
speaking of did you see that the cast of
funny girl is recording the original
Broadway soundtrack like for for like a
record
yeah like is that big news don't yes
they do that stuff no no only it's like
one of the Privileges you get as being
like the first it's the same as like
you're only eligible for the Tony you
only need to record one with beanie yes
oh okay that's a big deal no it's like
it's like really crazy but of course
like we want to [ __ ] listen to it
like [ __ ] and now we should be eligible
for Tony
I don't think so
rats
I need someone to explain the
eligibility when it comes to Tony's
because I'm not 100 sure but um they're
just like literally like rewriting
history they're like acting like beanie
never existed they should call the show
like funny girl too just so it's a new
show
funny woman woman of humor
girl that is funny girl in which there
is funny contact laughter laughter and
the humorous girl
[Laughter]
just so she could win a Tony
100
um well did you do your little no no I
was
brutally rebuffed by your scary dream so
without further Ado to do about the dude
Brothers here are the past size stories
that you need to know
today's episode is sponsored by
manscaped this holiday season I'm giving
thanks to my friends at manscaped I've
always wanted to make sure that whatever
I get my Mana something he's actually
going to use and their performance
package 4.0 is absolutely giving me my
money's worth Ben loves so many of the
products and his confidence has
definitely shot up since he started
using them for all of his grooming needs
gift your man manscape this holiday
season so his tree stands taller and if
you know what I mean help him join the
six million men worldwide who trust
manscaped and save 20 off and free
shipping when you go to manscape.com
toast so manscaped is really like Ben
has never been one to invest in like
personal like grooming or like skin care
he's just not into that but I literally
just got all the stuff for him from
manscape like the trimming the
performance package 4.0 he loves their
underwear too the leather case that
comes with it for travel like it's
really elevated Ben I feel like it makes
him into like a mature adult man now and
he actually has been using the nose hair
trimmer because he has like one nose
hair that grows out of his nose it like
literally does not stop coming back and
it's like every six months I'm like you
gotta pull it out again and I'm like
just use a nose hair trimmer and he was
a little a little scared it did sit on
our cabinet for a few months before I
used it but now he's like totally
addicted to it and I love it even though
I have to pick up the beard trimmings
it's a job I'm happy to do
so the performance package 4.0 I'm
inside you'll find the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer the crop preserver ball
deodorant crop reviver toner performance
boxer briefs and a travel bag to hold
all of the goodies it is a it is a
cornucopia for his balls and his body
gifting manscaped is the ultimate hack
to become the family favorite get 20 off
in free shipping at manscaped.com toast
that's 20 off and free shipping at
manscaped.com toast get him the best
gift of all for manscaped his balls will
thank you
today's episode is also brought to you
by
better help
thank you better help online therapy for
sponsoring today's episode unfortunately
life doesn't come with a user manual so
when it's not working for you it's
normal to feel stuck navigating any
life's challenges can make you feel
unsure whether it's a career change a
new therapist or becoming a parent
therapists are trained to help you
figure out what the cause of challenging
emotions and learn productive coping
skills and that makes therapy the
closest thing to a guided tour of the
complex engine called you as the world's
largest therapy service better help has
matched 3 million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
and if things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be more simple there's no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist while
there are so many benefits to
traditional therapy
um there are a lot of part a lot of
parts of it that can be uh like very
off-putting I think financially it's a
huge hurdle for a lot of people also
sitting in Waiting rooms and just like
the awkwardness of it all but taking it
all online that better help us down is
really really like removing some of
those hurdles
um so if you want to learn more and save
10 off your first month go to
betterhelp.com toast that's better
help.com slash t-o-a-s-t betterhelp.com
toast betterhelp is the world's largest
therapy service join the three million
people who have matched with
professionally licensed embedded
therapists and it's 100 online meaning
you can communicate via video chat phone
text anything that you're comfortable
with and yeah betterhelp.com toast
love it thank you
you're welcome our first story Harry
Styles and Olivia Wilde break up after
newly nearly two years together the
singer and his girlfriend Olivia Wilde
have broken up after nearly two years of
dating page six can confirm sources
first told people on Friday that they
were taking a break from their
relationship the source told people
quote he's still touring and is now
going abroad she is focusing on her kids
and her work in La it's a very amicable
decision The Source insisted that the
two are still very close while another
Insider adds right now they have
different priorities that are keeping
them apart
um so like this was so crazy I first of
all I cannot believe it's been two years
of this like it feels like we just saw
those pictures of them on the yacht
together no it feels like this has been
going on for a long time
and what's so weird is that like Harry
did his residency in La at The Forum and
the last show
um was like a couple days ago and she
was there with her daughter like it's
very weird like it's so confusing the
timing
um
I have a lot of thoughts like first of
all like I am happy this is over like I
think like it just it was not the right
relationship for Harry I'm like happy
for Olivia like that's really sick like
it's literally the book that I'm reading
it's fan fiction like you can't make
stuff up like this you know like the
hottest most eligible eligible bachelor
in the world wants you and Olivia Wilde
is gorgeous but you know she's older and
she's a mom like you just don't think
like that would happen like it's
literally a fairy tale I love it I'm
over it though like all the drama I'm
over it and I don't really know how
realistically like Harry does not stop
working and it was nice he was in you
know New York doing a residency so he
was there for a good amount of time he
was in LA doing a residency he was there
for a good amount of time both places
that like she lives and works but like
he's going abroad now to like his to
Asia like and I don't know how we can
realistically work with like a mom of
two who has like a bustling career it's
not feasible
yeah I just feel like this whole
announcement and like timing and split
is so calculated in the sense of they
can say it's because he's going abroad
because it obviously isn't feasible for
them to be together as much as they
would want to be but like if they're so
in love they've been together for two
years they could hold out while he's
working here and working there and I
feel like they kept the relationship on
track until he was done in the U.S so
that they could make it seem like
they're breaking up because of his
schedule and I just don't think it's
that at all I feel like things like got
really smelly a while ago
just like didn't want to like prove
everyone right or like say that you know
they shouldn't have been together on set
of the movie and and then the movie is
still like in theaters you know if
there's if they're breaking up and it's
like oh they you know Flo was directing
the movie for nothing and I feel like
they needed to stay together until this
point like the movie is went through its
power cycle they didn't want to have to
answer questions on the
you know panels while they're answering
a million other questions about all the
other drama and so I feel like they just
like held on
until they had a good enough reason they
could blame it on scheduling issues like
everyone else
no that's a really good call because I
think in order to deal with like the pr
[ __ ] that the mess that they went
through like you have to be like so in
love to not let it like a fact and I
don't think that's what this
relationship was I think it was like a
nice relationship I don't think it was
like a forever relationship I feel like
for Olivia she didn't want this
messiness to Cloud more than it already
did her movie Her accomplishments I feel
like for Harry like he doesn't want you
know he's doing his biggest stint in the
U.S to date and like where are the
people because like Olivia's a US star
like we care the most probably about
this relationship and like it would have
been every night every show it's like
people are would be screaming about this
or that and it's like I think both of
them were like let's just make it to
this point and then do whatever we want
I agree no I think it was it's like it's
amazing timing whether it was scheduled
or not it's impeccable time I feel like
it was scheduled and this was like the
finish line for them they've crossed it
they've crossed it I can sniff this out
because it's been smelly over there no I
agree I am like devastated that Harry is
like still working he absolutely needs
to take a break like it's giving Ariana
Grande he looks so tired like he has to
stop and every time I go on Instagram
and there's like another new poster love
on tour like whatever it's called
Harry's house on his Instagram I'm like
stop yeah
stop
well I look forward to seeing who he
dates next I feel like it'll be I feel
like it'll be me
it could be I feel like it'll be snitch
I heard a rumor that like he was at zero
Bond and like she was there and they
went through different entrances but
then like insiders inside said that they
were scene canoodling that's what I
heard oh that's interesting I didn't see
that oh no no you wouldn't have I just
heard it no yeah no I didn't hear it
either they were seen canoodling I heard
he was spotted at Nobu with uh
curvy podcaster that's what I heard
that's what I heard
[Music]
it's funny no I I agree like we were
there's so much I wasn't there at Nobu
oh I I feel like this is exciting for a
lot of different reasons one because
like I am over this Saga but two like
I'm genuinely like like so excited to
see who he dates next a lot of people
were really looking into the fact that
Kendall went to one of the final shows
in La at The Forum she went with Kylie
and Haley Bieber she walked around with
a bottle of 818. wait I'm like so behind
on Kardashians but I have one thing to
say did you see the episode where
Kendall went to Vegas no
well she wanted to go with Kylie for the
girls trip yeah and then Kylie didn't
have it coming okay yeah so she went
with like Justine and Haley and they had
they went to this day Club it was like
an 818 appear and she had to go and
she's literally having the worst time
and she's
in her confession I was being like I
just like don't like to do this like I
have anxiety like I'm not really like I
don't really like to party anymore like
that people don't realize like I'm not
like that at all like I don't really
like to drink like except 818.
it was so weird like I feel like it
invalidated her entire brand in like 30
seconds I really felt like they should
have cut it out
she's basically like everyone everyone
thinks this of me like they think so I'm
like this part of girl on this model I
go to parties I want to drink I want to
do this but like I actually hate it like
I hate all of it and I was like what
okay but I understand why you might
think that but there's a different you
can like be anti-partying anti-club and
like still like a nice drink like and by
the way tequila is actually meant to be
sipped not taking shots so like she can
be home with a glass of tequila no you
have to watch that is her you have to
watch it I will watch it but like just
because you don't want to party doesn't
mean that you don't it wasn't about it
was like she said she doesn't want to
drink
I think like drink as an aggressive
activity
I think that like what she was saying
could be the truth and she could still
love it when it I just think it was
definitely the wrong thing to say when
you're yeah because there will be people
who will just extrapolate I don't like
to drink and it's like well then why'd
you make
right alcohol I'm one of those people
yeah yeah but I think there's like other
forms of drinking ways to drink I agree
ways in which to drink things in which
to sip yes exactly
so I'll have to watch out you know
what's funny actually because I saw like
people were complaining like so many
Royal stories and it's like we go
through Seasons where we will talk about
something so much and then we haven't
like we used to talk about the
Kardashians every single day at certain
points over the last five years and like
we haven't had a story about them in
like almost a month I think we are like
and not for any reason just like there
hasn't been like huge major news I feel
like something big there was um nothing
like big enough to be a story like
they're popping up here and there but
like
there was a time where every single day
it was like new news and it's just funny
how things come in waves so no and also
just like the queen just passed away so
like some of us are still grieving but
soon we will move on
back to the Kardashians like I happen to
think the Kardashians like are in a flop
era right now like I have no desire to
talk about them when it was like two
months ago like I couldn't stop like I
was oozing out of me like I just think
they're going through like a like a
transitional period
I think their flop era was Chris
Humphries
but also like what do we constitute in
error then because if two months ago you
were obsessed and it's just two months
later and they're flopping I think it's
just like oh LOL like I don't think
they're flapping I just think they're
like quiet maybe they're home and
they're putting out I think they're
quiet really what are they doing like
other than
liking brand after brand like it's kind
of like it's kind of like enough
but in the last few months they are it's
not like they're launching Brands like
we were more obsessed with lemonade
Brands yeah and then Kim's
um
fund
but that's like it was just like it just
feels like a lot and then it's like when
you watch a show it's like all they do
is talk about the brands it's like a
shoot yeah that's my issue
yeah it just feels like it feels like we
might have hit like a like a point of
like enough with the promo and like I'm
not even bothered by promo I'm not one
of those people no it just needs to be
like good promo and you're giving us
more than just a commercial but that's
my issue with the show and I just feel
like when I think about their content
right now like it's more
I just feel like they're just living
life right now and not breaking the
internet every like the wedding yeah the
Positano was like crazy right you know I
feel like it seems like home with North
making tick tocks and I don't feel the
need to like she is report on it every
day yeah no no no they're they're not
doing anything that's worth reporting I
agree yeah except they went to that the
Harry Styles concert still like not a
story yeah cute not a story but but I
would definitely be here for a Kendall
and Harry reunion like I'm sorry some
people are just it's like how it's it's
like how the captain of the cheerleading
squad is meant to date the quarterback
Kendall Jenner is meant to date Harry
Styles like Beauty sees Beauty you know
what I mean I agree like if they got
together forever I would be thrilled
but based on what I know about them just
from their what they put out I feel like
they're too similar like I feel like no
they could be each other you know what I
mean no I I could see them just like
genuinely like not being compatible like
not getting along well I could feel that
that way because they're too similar
like they're both just like so free
spirited go with the flow like who's
gonna make the dessert dinner
reservation when both of them are so
okay whatever well they have a million
people for that okay but do you know
what like who's gonna take the
relationship that they have similar
personalities at all that's just from
The Vibes they put forth I feel like
they do they're both like so laid back
so chill man like okay so who's gonna
ask the one out but I don't think
Harry's like that like Kendall's
definitely like free spirit not like
other girls I'm a nerd hyperbaric
chamber but I don't think Harry is like
that I think Harry's like cool as [ __ ]
but what's his what's his personality
like I think he's probably like really
funny
um like very like cool in charge alpha
male you think he's in charge
yeah
okay I'm sorry to date a woman like 20
years your senior like you have to be
like you have to have it like it's
infantilizing he's like looking like
he's a baby
no no no no no no no
that's what I think because in in this
book that's literally about Harry Styles
and Olivia Wilde
um he's very much in charge
maybe I'm seeing it through the
perception of that okay I I mean and for
those who don't know what I'm talking
about I'm reading a book that's
literally fan fiction about like a 40
year old mom who gets like the Harry
Styles of her Generation Well of her
kids generation to fall in love with her
yes yes okay so I feel like that is
definitely influencing
this but I don't see the two of them as
similar personalities I feel like he is
really funny I just feel like they're
they're too similar
well they should date because they're
perfect for one another
but opposites physically for a reason
physically yeah well and that was only
our first story are you ready for our
next story
not if I don't freeze my tits off first
oh yeah how's it colder in here it's
getting colder it's not too warmer it's
getting colder in here yeah okay it's
getting okay we'll we'll pick this up
Second Story Adele kicks off her Vegas
residency she says thank you so much for
coming back to me you guys Adele has
finally kicked off her Las Vegas
residency after abruptly postponing it
in January on Friday night the Grammy
winner appeared on stage at the Coliseum
at Caesar's Palace the real Caesars
Palace in front of a crowd of more than
4 000 people including her son Angelo
and her boyfriend Rich Paul she said
thank you so much for coming back to me
it looks just like I imagined it would
she sang pretty much all of the hits and
she even got a little romantic during
the set embracing Rich Paul while
singing while when we were young and she
goes through the audience for that song
I'm sure everybody saw the videos if I
saw that yeah everybody saw it I've
pretty much seen the entire show on Tick
Tock like videos of every set every song
every outfit even though I don't think
she even changed outfits
um and it looks magnificent I mean looks
like a really Swanky evening like this
gorgeous theater they have this really
sickening LED screen system it's like
the whole stadium is one big screen it's
very cool
um but I am a hater to my core and I
want to say one thing it wasn't that
crazy that they couldn't pull it off the
first time I didn't see anything that I
was like oh they needed more time uh
there was rain water there was a piano
with pyrotechnics like it was on fire
there was a big confetti you know thing
of roses disappearing there was a big
screen I I it was stunning it really
looked amazing it didn't look like
anything that they couldn't pull off the
first time I was like oh I can't wait to
see this there's going to be like an
Olympic pool that opens up in the middle
of the audience like there was also a um
I forgot how many but I think 24 piece
Orchestra
it was really it was it was very elegant
I'm sure it was amazing but nothing that
couldn't have been done in January is
what you're saying the way that I see it
is I feel like the original show
actually wasn't going to have all of
this but she had to like add a bunch of
stuff so that now we'd be like oh well
of course it had to wait how would we
get the piano on fire without it that's
true but I don't think there was going
to be a fiery piano before no it's the
way I have like so many conspiracy
theories about this like relatively
innocuous event like okay she postponed
some shows like who cares I'm like I'm
kept up at night like I think there's I
feel like there's so much to this story
I can't explain it yeah but I think that
she's really redeemed herself the crowd
seemed to totally love and I think the
people who went night one were a lot of
her really big fans who were going to
the former night one she will be doing
the show until March 2023 uh and I feel
like within that time she will
completely like whenever we went over
like if there's all this content coming
out from every single show like
everything that happened earlier this
year will just be a distant memory and I
love that for her because she really is
so talented the show looks amazing when
I was watching When We Were Young of
course I had chills and like I literally
of course wasn't even it's just like her
in a dress walking around a theater and
no the lights are on the theater and
she's in the audience it just like looks
like
like it's not even like a regular it
does it just like looks like it tells at
a movie theater like it was crazy to see
no but also there's something about that
song that's like so powerful
it's it's a song that will like 10 out
of 10 make me cry always like I spent
like some of the lines I'm so mad I'm
getting old it makes me Reckless like
look like so powerful like I just that
song is Amazing obsessed I actually was
like then had to put it on after
um like on repeat just like get it out
of my system I was singing to Harry we
are having a great time thanks to
Adele's weekend at the Coliseum
no it was really it looked absolutely
stunning a little basic but stunning and
then I sang it to Harry and so then he
actually had an Adele concert private in
his room because we sound the same
because it was like a red-headed Queen
walking down his aisle and he said
everybody loves the things you do
keep running away you talk
to the way you moved that's tough It's
really low [ __ ] low
it's really hard everybody here is
watching you cause you feel like home
you're like a dream come true
I think that's pretty
it's so painful for me but if by chance
you're here alone
can I have a moment
before I go
cause I'm in by myself all night long
hoping yourself one
I Used to Know oh you look like a movie
you sound like a soul long my God this
reminds me
of When We Were Young
young let me photograph you in this
light in case it is the last time that
we might be exactly like we were before
we realized we were sad to get it old
and made us
Restless oh I'm so mad I'm getting old
it makes me Reckless
it like I'm so like delusional I'm like
that was literally like Adele like how
much different was it than Adele like
not that different that was beautiful
yeah no I if I closed my eyes I'm at the
Coliseum I close my eyes
oh also I actually took a screenshot of
this because I went on my Spotify to
play When We Were Young so I pressed I
typed in when
and the most fire songs of all time
start with when are you ready let me
think let me think when
when I pray for you Dan and Shay no that
one didn't even come up though a fellow
fire song When We Were Young When I Was
Your Man Bruno Mars when it rains it
pours Luke Combs When I Look At You
Miley Cyrus it was just a wild ride and
then it turned into like the playlists
and whatnot but right no that's that's
really uh when is it really powerful
word
I agree
it's beautiful okay let's get to our
next story
is it the next story that's brought to
you
is it yep
your bedroom deserves a refresh and now
is the perfect time to elevate the most
important bed the most important room
excuse me in your home with thuma
introducing the bed by thuma handcrafted
from eco-friendly high quality upcycled
wood you'll find beautiful unique
variations in the natural grain the
minimalist design featuring Japanese
joinery helps Elevate any space it's
super supportive for your mattress it's
breathable and it's made to naturally
minimize noise and create space the
perfect platform bed frame just got
better as well because you can now
customize the bed by thuma by choosing
between the original pillow board or
their new solid wood headboard the
fabric pillar board adds a nice softness
and color to any space while the
headboard headboard offers solid Sleek
support the headboard attaches directly
to the bed using Japanese joinery with
no tools required you can buy it on its
own or as an upgrade
or with the bed
um so you guys know like setting up
Furniture is the bane of my existence as
a human being and the bed by thurma like
really is that [ __ ] it comes in three
boxes
I would say around five minutes like no
divorce contemplation necessary it's
really that easy and it's a really great
sturdy beautiful bed Jackie has one in
her guest room and along with the bed
they offer other bedroom Essentials at
thuma they have like the The Mattress
the nightstand the side table they are
perfect compliments to the bed so create
that feeling of checking into your
favorite boutique hotel suite but at
home with the bed by thuma now go to
thuma.co toast to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase
your purchase of the bed and you get
free shipping in the Continental us when
you go to thuma dot Co thuma.co toast
t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash toast for that 25
credit
gorgeous thank you yeah well come
what can I say except getsuma
love that okay our next story we don't
have a whole AMA story but the headline
of the evening is that Kelly Rowland
asked the 2022 amas crowd to chill out
after Chris Brown won and booze were
elicited from his win
no if you saw the clip like it's
literally like it's so awkward it's like
major loser moment for Kelly Rowland and
I actually was just watching Kelly
Rowland on The Today Show and I was
actually gonna come on here and like I
just wanted to talk about Kelly Rowland
today before I saw this clip just to be
like she was she was on The Today Show
talking with Jenna Bush Hager because
Destiny's Child performed at George
Bush's inauguration and they like gave
Kelly they gave Jenna Bush like a
present and Jenna Bush was saying it was
like one of her favorite memories from
being in the White House and like Kelly
Merlin was being so funny and she looked
so beautiful and it was just like I
forgot I forget about Kelly Rowland
sometimes and I wanted to come on here
and be like honestly Kelly Rowland is
like that [ __ ] but she really was
acting like a big enormous loser at the
amas and now we have to talk about that
yes so last night at the amas uh Kelly
Rowland presented the favorite male R B
artist and Chris Brown one Chris was not
in attendance to accept his reward the
crowd was cheering and booing and Kelly
finished by saying excuse me chill out I
want to tell Chris thank you so much for
making great r b music and I want to
tell him thank you for being in
incredible performer I'll take this
award bring it to you I love you
congratulations
yikes like major major yikes for Kelly
Rowland
um
I imagine they didn't have an easy time
finding someone who wanted to give an
award away to Chris Brown because I
don't think the AMA awards are like a
big secret like who wins it's like
predetermined you know so it's not van
voted
I don't know you know what I mean it's
not like Taylor won all the awards well
because she's Taylor but also because
she was there it's like you know whoever
yes wins you know
um and it's clear that Kelly Rowland has
some weird relationship with Chris Brown
and that's a weird Flex on her and
honestly I'm looking at Kelly Rowland a
little differently this morning
yeah
just because
all around bizarre also
like I thought like a ward shows don't
give Awards like to
yeah why are we nominating Chris Brown
right like they don't typically not they
they editorialize the awards like based
on everyone's uh Behavior
yeah no this is definitely like a weird
Flex for everyone involved
um I didn't know that Chris Brown like
gotta like I know that Chris Brown
releases music which sure go for it I
know that people still like his music
and go to his concerts sure I'm not
going to stop anyone but I do think it's
weird to like Embrace him like like he
didn't literally beat the [ __ ] out of a
woman
it's like on the very end degrees of
like scandals like Chris Brown's is the
worst like it's the worst domestic
violence is not a [ __ ] joke like it's
so weird yeah it's so weird how like
people like
forget but like they they don't like
most most I'd say most people like don't
forget like Chris Brown I think we
collectively have all just been like
leave us alone but like there are these
weird moments where like Kendall Jenner
was in his music video like it's so
[ __ ] weird yeah
like what am I missing
he did that no I don't know but like we
must be missing something because he did
that [ __ ] no yeah he did that [ __ ] so
it's like
I saw the picture of Rihanna like that's
literally all and it wasn't even like
like it was not that it would make a
difference but it wasn't even like it
was somebody not famous like it's
[ __ ] Rihanna we all know like it's so
weird yeah it wasn't like alleged and
someone said like we saw it's Rihanna
and there's a picture
and a police report yeah
and I don't think that's something you
do just one time yeah it's a pattern so
I can't feel my fingertips but [ __ ] you
Chris Brown
uh so it was a big night for Taylor at
the amas yeah so obviously she won all
the awards like no offense who cares
like those awards are fraudulent like I
like whatever it's like she's the most
awarded woman in ama history like who
cares those are fake Awards but what I
did think was really interesting is that
you know when Taylor goes to an award
show she like has like a BFF like
another Celeste sidekicker a sidekick
like hug her and it was Sabrina
Carpenter which I love I love Sabrina
Carpenter but like a few like award
shows ago it was Olivia Rodrigo so like
it's just weird and there has been like
a lot of stuff on Tick Tock like
conspiracy theories about Olivia Rodrigo
and Taylor Swift like having beef which
I just find interesting okay I have a
couple things to say one I think even if
they had beef and they had a falling out
like I think it would be unbelievably of
Taylor unbelievably Petty of Taylor to
seek Out Sabrina Carpenter and like make
her her new pet so I don't think that's
what it is I feel like it's more so
Taylor being like we can support all
women like I don't have to choose
between Olivia or Sabrina we're all
talented women we all love to sing and I
think we all sing I can be friends with
both of them I think that's the larger
message that you would want to share
regardless of her current relationship
status with Olivia Rodrigo like I don't
think it's out of spite or anything but
I also think it's [ __ ] weird that she
keeps bringing that she always has like
a little pet at award shows like always
someone there who she can hug who's like
her flavor of the moment like I know
that that was like a season that she was
in a while ago but like I can't believe
she's like still
I don't think it's weird
um because she refuses to bring her
boyfriend out in public like so she
can't she wears Abigail where's her mom
like she has so many friends and she has
so many friends that like we know are
her best friends like Selena bring
Selena and that's not like yeah it's
always like just this like recycling
thing I mean so on the other side of her
was that at that singer Gail who's
opening up for her ABC and like honestly
like that made me upset because like
okay so I go viral on Tick Tock and I
can sit next to Taylor like I was so
upset yeah I guess the positive spin
here is like it could be you one day
that's true that's true we know she
heard toast by Claudia ashrae because
she wrote maroon so she well we know she
at least heard 100 oh sorry 100 was the
one uh
so it's possible just like it's about
fire music like you could be opening up
for Taylor
yeah I know that like a lot of times
when Taylor goes to award shows her like
Sidekick is Trey her publicist and every
all the fans know trees she's like this
gorgeous redhead
um so I like when she does that because
it feels genuine I agree like this like
rotating door of pop stars it's like
so I agree so yeah and but I will say
now a positive like I love the respect
that Taylor has for redheads I just feel
like she's a redhead style and yeah
because some people are RedHead phobic
they are and I don't know that she
respects redheads I agree I actually had
a very tailor-filled weekend I watched
um reputation again I watched 1989 World
Tour
um actually took an edible which like I
never do and I was up till two in the
morning like sobbing watching 1989 I was
really just like that was such a moment
in time it was it's really probably one
of the greatest piece of
like Works ever created yeah
it was amazing it was amazing I had a
very Taylor weekend too but I've noticed
that now when I listen to midnights I
started from snow on the beach I don't
[ __ ] with whatever's above there
oh wow that's so funny I don't [ __ ] with
snow on the beach I love it so much I
mean it's not my favorite but I always
start with it and on my like songs it's
the last one that I liked so it's
probably gonna be my most played song of
the album even though it's not my
favorite song I'm just I won't listen to
anti-hero Lavender Haze and maroon
because it reminds me too much of toast
wait those are like three of the best
ones
not enough to
the first one by the way I do think you
actually probably would love maroon I
don't know why you don't like that one I
know I like it but like there's not
enough smart t-shirt when you Splash one
to me and now the blood rushed into my
cheeks so Scarlet it was maroon it's
getting colder in here I'm literally not
okay okay let's move on good thing our
next story is about Taylor because she
put out a statement on Friday about The
Ticket Master disaster is that what
they're calling it because they should
be I don't know
disaster the Ticketmaster disaster
she said well it goes without saying
that I'm extremely protective of my fans
we've been doing this for decades
together and over the years I brought so
many elements of my career in-house I've
done this specifically to improve the
quality of my fans experience by doing
it myself with my team who cares much
about my fans as I do it's really
difficult for me to trust an outside
entity with these relationships and
loyalties and excruciating for me to
just watch mistakes happen with no
recourse she said there was a multitude
of reasons why people added such a hard
time trying to get tickets and is trying
to figure out how to improve the
disastrous rollout moving forward she
said I'm not going to make excuses for
anyone because we asked them multiple
times if they could handle this time of
this type of demand and we were assured
that they could she said it's truly
amazing that 2.4 million people got
tickets but it really pisses me off that
a lot of them feel like they went
through several bear attacks to get them
she said she hopes to provide more
opportunities to get together with her
fans who weren't able to get tickets
so I don't know if that like is code for
like her maybe releasing more shows but
I think the general message of this um
statement was like not my fault like
it's 100 on Ticketmaster like General
Message is I'm pissed too I'm not sorry
because I didn't do anything and I
pissed and it was wrong and there was a
bear no and I um I endorse that message
like don't apologize if it's not your
[ __ ] fault and then also then reports
came out that I think were probably
directly from Taylor's
um team that Taylor opted not to opt
into Dynamic pricing and Ticketmaster
did it anyway
damn
um
yeah so
cool or Taylor doesn't change you know
like annoying for Taylor
um I don't know if she's gonna
add more shows anyone wanting an update
on my ticket situation it has not
changed it probably won't change for
quite a few months by the way I saw that
actually the the rate at which you were
able to get tickets for Taylor Swift
arrows tour was actually more difficult
than getting into Harvard
percentage-wise uh five percent of
applicants get into Harvard two percent
of ticket holders Scott tickets
we'll now move for two because I didn't
get errors tickets and I didn't get into
Harvard yeah but like
had tickets that you could have gotten
gotch like because she like yes in that
moment we could have gotten those
expenses could have gotten back of the
floor seats but I imagine if we had
clicked them and gotten through we
wouldn't have even um been able to
process like that happened to everyone I
don't think we would have like just
because they were there doesn't even
mean anything they would have been in
someone else's car too
got it okay so
so they have no regrets I tried my
hardest that's where we're at I feel
like she's saying that she'll add more
shows but they haven't been done yet so
she's not gonna promise anything that
she can yeah I mean it's just so crazy
like Taylor really is that [ __ ] yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story I'm voraciously hungry and which
like never has really happened to me on
the show because I usually eat before
but I didn't today and like oh my God
I'm so hungry do you think the
microphone is picking up the Never
no like I don't always but did I have
maybe sometimes I'll have like a Fiber
One bar I had a light dinner because I
had a big brunch
um nice just fun fact about me
what's the final story a little Biz news
that everyone's talking about Bob Iger
is returning as Disney CEO in shocking
shake-up what's old is new again at
Disney Bob Iger is officially back as
CEO in a shocking tournaments the media
giant announced late Sunday that Iger
will return to lead the company as its
CEO effective immediately
all junior girls to the gymnasium
immediately thank you for understanding
the Trope Bob Iger replaces Bob chappick
who has stepped down from his position
after less than three years on the job
wow it's already been three years since
Bob Iger since we've been talking about
this
Iger spent more than four decades at
Disney including 15 years as CEO and
according to the company he will serve a
CEO for two years with a mandate from
the board to set the Strategic direction
for renewed growth and to work closely
with the board in developing a successor
to lead the company at the completion of
his term if you look at the stock chart
of Disney it's definitely gone down
since Bobby
since this year oh this is the year to
date let's do five years let's look at
it from five years oh yeah peaked in
June 2020 and then went down from there
and is that when he left they said two
years right
three
when did he say
I this is a story like that you know of
course we normally wouldn't talk on but
like something about Bob Iger like we're
obsessed like Bob Iger has Pizzazz he
has Charisma I'm sure there's like a
story about him I don't want to know I
think he is like if I had a company and
they were like we could hire anyone to
be the CEO like Bob Iger like I just I
trust him and I feel like I don't know
what's wrong with Disney I didn't even
know they were like in trouble or
anything but I did think it was weird
when he stepped down because he was like
this like really popular like everyone
was obsessed like I knew the CEO of
Disney's name like it was so weird but
it was because Bob Iger like was that
[ __ ] you know yeah I agree he's
definitely one of the first businessmen
that come to mind and I don't know
because he did a master class that's why
I don't know if Bob iger's daughters are
toasters we hope that they are so
um yeah I feel like he's definitely also
branded himself as America's businessman
but I also feel like it's not that hard
to be the CEO of Disney and be
successful at it like it's literally
like big red like I gave these shares to
on a platter
so [ __ ] true like everyone except
those cheers were stolen but yeah
the chairs were stolen
what are you talking about chairs cheers
big red bring it on
um still big right so many references on
the show and and then I feel like you
don't even realize what I'm talking
about because that happened last week
too with Mr Hall and Miss Geist yeah no
like sometimes I you know people say I'm
Mumbo but like you low-key Mumble too I
do Mumble okay
I feel like being the CEO of Disney is
so easy it's all there on a platter just
like big red gave her cheers to Torrance
though I thought you were saying the
chairs the cheers were stolen from the
clovers I agree okay I thought you were
saying chairs and I'm just like nodding
because I'm like I'm freezing I'm like I
don't know what's going on like I can't
[ __ ] feel my toes I'm like there's
like a like an inch of skin beneath my
pant like between my shoe and my pant
and like a seriously I'm gonna have to
go to the hospital yeah okay I I'll I'll
I do know that like I seriously Mumble
sometimes especially if not given the
time no but that was an amazing
reference okay thank you and I just want
to say like the larger point being I
think it's really easy to be the CEO of
Disney unless you're Bob traffic and
you're [ __ ] up left and right but
like literally do nothing like let the
movies do their movies like higher like
keep rehiring the same people who did
like Disney lin-man Frozen Let It Go
Frozen lin-manuel like like it's working
it's working like those amusement parks
run themselves like definitely get the
pedophiles out of there because it's
like oh that's where kids go I think
that'll probably be the hardest part of
working at Disney is like making sure to
keep it a file free zone
so if you're the CEO of Disney are you
also the CEO of like Hulu and [ __ ]
Disney owns ABC and Hulu yeah
like what's the parent company of Disney
Disney so that means like Hulu and ABC
ESPN like they're under your jersey they
all fall under yes like yeah
no it's you have the Kardashian job
you have Monday night football Sunday
Night Football Carrie Underwood
Sunday night
oh
Sunday night you have tell me lies like
[ __ ] figure it out
[ __ ] figure it out [ __ ] next you
know you just need a morning show you
know what else you have the Mickey Mouse
Clubhouse come inside it's fun inside
and by the way if things aren't going
well in the Mickey Mouse Clubhouse I
don't know just a quiet Mouse a crier
Miss Rachel
do you know the Miss Rachel drama I
heard she got hate and you know what she
got a letter somebody wrote was it an
email
email okay a very upsetting letter via
email nobody knows what it was but miss
Rachel referenced that it happened and
it was like very jarring for her in the
community so everyone is just sending
Miss Rach love okay I just want to say
Mr H is never gonna make it in this
business one email email girl have you
read that have you read the Reddit page
about us girl welcome to the internet
honestly like you need a thicker skin
one I'm sorry that Mr H got hate like
protected inexcusable inexcusable
but it makes me feel a little better
because it's like even more
so [ __ ] true like you could not that
I would wish hate you could be literally
perfect teaching children how to talk
just like the sweetest woman on the
internet and you're gonna get hate so
like might as well do your thing on your
podcast
so [ __ ] true I'm gonna do my thing
um yeah I just want to make sure you
were in the know with what Mr H was
doing but somebody should get their
hands on Miss rage I the second I I was
introduced to our content I told Olivia
I'm like somebody is missing out like
somebody needs to buy her outright they
need to license her brand she should be
doing songs that like
monthly kits well you can subscribe and
get her toys and she plays with the toys
on the show it's like she could have the
next baby shark like song wise if she
came up with one of her dumb songs like
kids would [ __ ] eat that [ __ ] up
mommy put it on in the car and Mommy
Mommy of course literally there's I feel
like she's not doing enough no I agree
and so and maybe maybe Miss Rachel isn't
a capitalist maybe that's why her brand
growth has been staggered maybe she's
just like you know she's not in it for
the money but like if I was if I had the
if I had the momentum or straight Chad
like you'd better believe you'd find me
raking it in sure it's not even about
the money it's about the quality of the
content like I feel like it's like you
know so nice Miss Rachel does it from
her bedroom but it's like okay now
you're like a big Channel with millions
of viewers like step it up
yeah and a big company can help you do
that so it's not just about the money
it's about the quality of content that
she's giving to the campers 100 and the
campers deserve the best the best of the
best the creme de La Creme that means
cream anyways Disney like if I can
figure it out it really shouldn't be so
hard no but congrats to Bob Iger like I
don't I think he was you know he stepped
down before his time was up yeah and a
lot of people don't like retirement
exactly you know uh
Logan Roy
right
right so I think that's what happened
here and the other guy stunk it up he
stunk
so those were the Fast Five you
definitely need to know every single one
of them but we're not done because we
have some fabulous TV recap last night's
new episode of Yellowstone and the White
Lotus will be brought to you by Haya
typical children's vitamins are
basically candy in Disguise they're
filled with two teaspoons of sugar
unhealthy chemicals and other gummy junk
that Growing Kids should never eat so
that's why Haya was created the
pediatrician approved super powered
chewable vitamin While most children's
vitamins are filled with five grams of
sugar and can contribute to a variety of
health issues Haya is made with zero
sugar and zero gummy junk yet it tastes
great and is perfect for picky eaters
Haya fills in the most common gaps in
modern children's diets to provide the
full body nourishment that our kids need
with a yummy taste that they love
formulated with the help of nutritional
experts Haya is pressed for the blend of
12 organic fruits and vegetables then
it's supercharged with 15 essential
vitamins and minerals including vitamin
D B12 C zinc folate all the things Ben
carries in his backpack
it's non-GMO it's vegan it's dairy free
it's allergy free it's gelatin free it's
nut free and it's everything else that
you can imagine and it is designed for
kids of all ages it's sent straight to
your door so parents have one less thing
to worry about and one of our favorite
things about Haya is like obviously it's
a great vitamin but it's also like a
little activity for the kid because the
bottle is so cute and it comes with like
stickers and like you could decorate the
bottle kaler loves it so it's like you
get five minutes a piece while the kid
is playing with the bottle and the
stickers and you're also supercharging
your kid up with great vitamins and
nutrients we have a special deal with
Haya for their best selling children's
vitamin receive 50 off your first order
to claim the deal you have to go to
highahealth.com toast it is not
available on the regular website only at
Haya Health
h-i-y-a-h-e-a-l-t-h.com slash toast to
get your kids the full body nourishment
that they need to grow into healthy
adults all right what do you want to
start with for TV recap
we could start with Yellowstone because
I just have one episode and then you'll
do
so if you want to do headphones off I'm
going to take my headphones off for
yours because I'm going to watch light
Lotus I just did not get around to it
this weekend headphones are off wave at
me when you're when you're done I'm
gonna be like warming up my ankles will
do okay last night's episode of
Yellowstone was so good I was enjoying
myself a few times and honestly things
got really high when they went to the
bar in Bozeman and then they got really
low because Beth got arrested which I
feel like is a much bigger deal than
we're realizing in this episode because
like she has all this stuff going on
with market equities and you don't want
your girl like having charges pressed
against her so while I was loving the
bar content like her and rip dancing I
could watch a whole movie of them like
Beth was just looking gorgeous they were
being just happy which I think is an
emotion that they both you know struggle
to achieve given everything that they've
been through it was just like so
beautiful so of course things had to go
wrong also them paying respect to like
their fellow Cowboys down the bar like
sending whiskey shots like I was just
loving the cowboy of it all and
obviously like they're real cowboys not
like these other fake Cowboys oh so I
want to know what a fake Cowboy is like
give me give me the Deeds other than
that things are heating up you know
market equities versus schwarzen Meyer
I'm gonna be honest I didn't understand
a lot of that I feel like I re I figured
it out towards the end when I was going
to sleep I was like okay I need to try
and understand what happened with
schwarzeneyer so schwarzeneyer was the
company that
Beth used to work for and the CEO of
schwarzeneyer was the guy who played
summer Roberts's dad from the OC and
like at first they were boys and Beth
was like doing amazing work for him
buying up all this Ranch Land in Montana
she was like pretty much building you
know a border around her dad's land but
then summer Roberts's dad sold that land
to market equities so Beth was pissed
but then I guess Beth is still a
majority shareholder in Schwartz and
Meyer so she sold her something to
market equities competitor
in order to get that land back question
mark whatever whatever she did really
[ __ ] you know the um evil old lady
over at Market Equity so that was great
however the weak [ __ ] link Jamie
Dutton is gonna ruin it all he like
comes into his office like so big and
bad talking [ __ ] to the lawyer and the
minute like a pretty lady him a
compliment he's a big [ __ ] dope and
that's why we can't have nice things
that's why Jamie is the worst I feel
like when I said my recap last week like
you can't trust Jamie he is the worst
like
I feel like he's so diabolical like at
least Beth has her loyalties she'll do
everything you know unethically to stay
true to the people that she loves but
like she knows where she stands Jamie is
just all over the place and like he has
no loyalties honestly he has no Scruples
Beth though violent and wild is a
scrupled woman I believe like she stands
by her man like she stands by the
thousand marriage you want to hit on
your man you're gonna get cracked with a
beer bottle it's just what's gonna
happen
um not that I endorse that whatsoever
so it was a wonderful episode per usual
oh Casey and Monica all very very sad
and honestly I really hope that rain
water does not get you served I think
he's a really good leader and I'm liking
that like there's the Dutton Rainwater
appreciation you know mutual respect so
John is gonna have to step it up also
this content about like the 90s and the
Wolves I'm sure we're about to see them
have done something like really terrible
that's gonna come back to bite John in
the butt as Governor because like that's
the kind of [ __ ] market equities does
but all in all just another great day of
saving the ranch
and uh I think that's pretty much it
okay you're good
good let's see yep welcome back okay
thank you uh how was your recap good I
think it was really good I think I broke
down some things that might have been a
little confusing because I know they
were confusing for me and talk about the
highs and the lows all right you want to
take your headphones off now yep
okay so I started the new season of
White Lotus it's in Sicily which by the
way is really making me want to go to
Sicily it's like a really really nice um
spot that they picked and it's nice to
have the gang back together I'm so glad
that Jennifer Coolidge is going to be
like a Mainstay in this show because
she's really so [ __ ] funny and now
that she brought her assistant we have
like a little extra you know a little
drama for the young kids now for me the
most interesting like group of people at
the hotel is Megan Fahey Theo James
Aubry Plaza and her husband like there's
so many like intricacies of marriage
there that I think are really
interesting and I don't know who we're
supposed to like and who we're not
supposed to like I feel like we're
supposed to hate
Daphne and like the rich people like who
were already rich the blonde Megan Faye
I feel like we're supposed to hate her
in Theo James because like they're
shallow and like cheat on each other and
materialistic but like uh I [ __ ] love
them and I think those other two Aubry
Plaza like I think they're [ __ ]
Dreadful like they're so negative so
boring our Republic is like such a
[ __ ] storm cloud I don't know how
anyone could be married to her so I
don't know like who's we're supposed to
like but I don't like Aubry Plaza and
also seeing Aubrey Plaza play like a
really serious kind of buttoned up
uptight woman is like really jarring for
me and like it's taking some time to get
adjusted to it now the two prostitutes
who are running around the hotel are
really [ __ ] pissing me off like how
are they still at the hotel like they
stopped having sex with that guy like
three days ago and he should just take
them off his room reservation like every
time he sees them he gets anxiety
because he doesn't want everyone to know
he [ __ ] the prostitutes it's like
they're only in the [ __ ] hotel
because you put their names on your room
so take them off your [ __ ] room
because it's a hotel for guests only so
stop now I don't also really know what's
going on with the concierge Valentina
like is she in love with that other
employee because that employee said one
nice thing to her like girl you can't
think everyone's in love with you when
they give you a compliment like she was
just trying to like get you to calm down
so that's gonna be awkward
um
what else that family like the dad the
grandpa and the son who are all
traveling to like the Grandpa's Hometown
like I kind of don't like them and I
don't know who's gonna end up being like
the subject of the murder I feel like
it's gonna be the Theo James Megan Fahey
Aubry Plaza crew because like they're
the most interesting in my opinion
um I don't know I feel like Jennifer
Coolidge definitely is not going to get
murdered because we're not going to be
the murderer because I feel like she's
just gonna be a Mainstay in the show
from now on like she's not really a part
of that plot but maybe that'll be like a
something they throw at us who else is
staying at the hotel is that a
I think so
um overall it's just like a really good
show I'll never get over the fact that
Ned schnably from school of rock is a
creator and producer of it
um and there is like a lot of
unnecessary like sex and nudity but it's
so good so I don't really care
um really fabulous show fabulous time
fabulous people Jackie Jackie Jackie
look up from your phone Jackie look up
from your phone yeah there you go okay I
got her back
good um you didn't really miss anything
honestly nothing has really happened to
White Lotus it's just like a nice show
with like beautiful people you know
that's the show and then like everything
happens at the end it was like getting
to know everyone it's really character
development yeah
um so that was a TV recap brought to you
by two very different girls and I am
going to be watching right White Lotus I
hope to rejoin you next week for the
Recaps I was hoping for this week but it
just didn't happen for me this weekend
there was just so much going on
um so that is our show a nice long one
for today's Monday episode reminder that
there's only episodes Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday this week because Thursday and
Friday we are off for Thanksgiving the
best holiday of the year so I hope
everyone's having you know a nice
holiday kickoff to their holiday getting
their preparations done putting up the
tray the Garland the manoira
um it's just a great time of year so
don't forget to acknowledge that space
and thanks for listening to the toast
acknowledge the space you guys I'll be
doing Thanksgiving prep over on my
Instagram so make sure to follow me on
Jackie ashrae because someone is popping
off on reels someone
is that the truth thank you so much for
listening to the toast of the Monday
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories you need to know everybody
Friday on YouTube for watching us on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available
podcast
videos
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an amazing Monday have a great day
and we'll see you tomorrow goodbye